as social animals our success our
happiness our joy our ability to get
anything done requires help you need to
ask for help you cannot do this alone
the whole solopreneur thing I'm gonna do
it by myself I'm gonna work from home
that's it's not evil
rise and shine
it's an espresso time what's up belief
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
get help over to you simon Sinek also if
you want to know what simon Sinek and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 2:54 confident
series where every day for the next 254
days I will send you a morning video for
free to help you build your confidence
to link to join is in the description
below you get the benefit of hearing
what everybody else has to think before
you render your opinion it's like a
hammer you can use it broadly or
narrowly you can build a table you can
build a house it's the same tool there's
a paradox being a human being
unfortunately at all times every moment
of every day we are both individuals and
members of groups right we are both
responsible for ourselves and our
happiness in our own joy but at the same
time we're members of families or
members of churches or members of teams
were members of companies like we're
members of multiple groups every single
day every moment and this produces in
complications we have to make decisions
so do we put ourself first or do we put
the group first and there's a debate
some people say oh you have to take care
of yourself before you can take care of
the group and some say no no you take
care of the group and that's what helps
they will take care of you and the
answer is yes it's not one or the other
it's actually both simultaneously it is
a challenge but at the end of the day
there's no getting around it as social
animals our success our happiness our
joy our ability to get anything done
requires help
and those who embrace the fact that they
cannot do everything alone that they
need the support and love and it doesn't
mean somebody who's physically helping
you live something sometimes it might be
someone who just believes in you these
things are essential and there's just no
getting around it if you want to be
successful then you have to get over
your fear of asking people for help
some people will reject you some people
will laugh at you
some people will ignore you you'll have
to swallow your pride but you have to
get over it you cannot do this alone not
if you have a big vision for yourself
and your ability to ask for help will
determine how far you go so in my first
business I was afraid to ask for help
and it really hurt me I was in
university I had a software company it
was me and two partners and we were
struggling I was making a few hundred
dollars a month barely eaten barely able
to survive really really rough days and
what made it harder on myself was I was
too ashamed and embarrassed to ask my
friends for help I was too embarrassed
to tell them that I wasn't having
success I had to pick one thing a month
that I could go to because they didn't
have the money because I was making $300
a month and $20 for pizza and beer was
expensive for me right so I had to pick
one thing per month that I could go to
to celebrate with my friends and it
meant that I wasn't hanging out with my
friends I meant that I missed a lot of
birthday parties and other you know fun
things that you do when you're in
university if I just asked for help but
would have made things a lot easier
my friends honestly would have
understood my friends would have said
that's okay we can find a way not to
spend money or somebody could have
spotted me but instead I was saying well
I'm living the entrepreneur lifestyle
you know I'm just too busy right now
I'm grinding I'm chasing my dream I
really I just felt really bad about
myself because I wasn't able to hang out
with my friends and I was too ashamed
and embarrassed to go ask for help so
whether it's asking your friends for
emotional support whether it's reaching
out to potential customers partner
suppliers for for business support
whether it's connecting with investors
for investment support whether it's
trying to reach out to mentors and ask
for guidance and wisdom you need to ask
for help you cannot do this alone if you
try to do this alone for the rest of
your life
your vision will never be realized
unless you just have a super tiny
version of what you want to do in your
life
now if you reaching out to strangers I
want to give you three ways that will
help you stand out and get a yes back
from them so you can move forward with
success step number one is be a known
quantity the more that that person knows
you the more likely they're gonna say
yes and support you so it was an example
people reach me all the time on my
YouTube my Instagram they say hey Evan
can you support me can you check out my
page can you read this business plan can
you give me feedback on this idea that I
have and I look at their account and I
have no idea who they are and for many
of them it's the first time they're
reaching out to me or being involved in
my community at all and so the
likelihood of you getting an answer is
pretty low there's still some people
that will respond to but it's pretty low
because I'm bombarded I get tons of
messages it's really just the luck if I
happen to be on at that time and you
show up at the top I might respond to
you but there are other people in my
community who are super involved who
respond the comments on every single
video who are on all of my live chats
who join me on my Instagram live feeds
who've come in and volunteered and been
a part of the events that I'm putting on
there's people who I know by name and by
face who are gorgeous loving members of
believe nation and for those people I'll
do almost anything I'll read their
business plan I'll give them advice I'll
try to open up doors and contacts and
suggestions and ideas and getting on a
call with them and help them because
they're a known quantity and so that's
your job before ever trying to ask for
help try to figure out how can you be a
known quantity check out where that
person is engaging are they active on
YouTube on Twitter on Facebook on
Instagram where they actually involved
in the comments see how you can go to
their events and volunteer and just be a
part of the community try to bring value
somehow to them so that you are already
a known quantity and they are tripping
over themselves to try to help you tip
number two is share the story so you
have a story you're trying to accomplish
something I want to know what that story
is beyond just I'm trying to make a lot
of money if that's your story you need
to get a better story just in general as
an entrepreneur but chances are you have
a story there's a meaning there's this
purpose behind what you're doing and the
more people can understand this story
they're more likely to connect with you
and want to help you so as an example
we're going to LA as part of my becoming
tour and Danny my videographer his
heroes aren't a choice and Egger and
we're trying to get a meeting with
Arnold Schwarzenegger just so that Danny
can have a quick one on one to say how
much that he
meant to him because Danny was
overweight and introverted and super shy
and by listening to Arnold's tapes he
became a new man and he started working
out he started making friends I started
to believe in himself and have more
confidence and so we're trying to work
out a way that by me going into
California and maybe do an interview
with Arnold on my channel we can have
Danny and Arnold meet and it would make
Danny's entire life and so we put a
video up on my channel basically
explaining the story of what it meant to
him and we're hoping that that spreads
we're trying to share it with our
community to share with you guys maybe
somebody out there has a connection that
we can show this video to Arnold and he
says yes I want to meet you guys come
over it's the story that matters so if
you're reaching out to somebody what's
your story why should I care not just
hey I've got this quick question what
camera do you use
right tell me the story make me feel
something step number one is being known
quantity and now like make me feel this
story make me feel connected to you as a
human because when I'm connected to you
a much more willing to help and set
number three is feel the hustle make
them feel your hustle the worst part of
being a mentor when somebody reaches out
to you is they don't take the advice it
feels like you're not gonna take the
advice mentors love giving back they
love helping we love helping it's it's
one of our favorite things to do in the
world but the thing that we hate doing
the most in the world is wasting our
time because it's our biggest asset and
so here's the thing most mentees never
take action on the advice that is given
so it's the thing that we love doing the
most giving back and helping with the
thing that we hate to impose which is
wasting our time so you need to show the
hustle I need to feel like if I give you
advice you're gonna go off and do that
work and so I remember there was this
one woman who reached out to me and said
hey Evan I would love five minutes of
your time I have I have one really
important question to ask you even if
it's while you are walking to your car I
will come with a smile on my face and
bring you coffee and a donut because
this would really mean the world to me
and so from that I gave her half an hour
minute of Starbucks and and I helped her
but it showed the hustle right it showed
the drive and showed the enthusiasm make
me feel like if I spent some time with
her she'll actually value that time and
apply it to her life into her
to get a result and so you want to stand
out from everybody else who's r asking
these people for help because you are
showing how much you are willing to
hustle for it so be a known quantity
share your story and make them feel your
hustle those are some of the ways that
you can stand out reach out to get the
help that you need but please please
just understand how important it is that
you can't do this alone
that you have a big mission that you are
worthy that you deserve help that you
need help to get to where you want to go
and not to let your pride or your ego or
your fear of rejection or embarrassment
or shame like I did get in the way of
you getting to where you need to go
because the world needs the thing that's
in here to come out now I've got a
really special bonus clip for you that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for question of the day I want
to know which three people are you going
to reach out to let me know put it down
the comments below
culture in our society you can do some
phenomenal things individually but
they'll never reach their full potential
unless you do them collectively you have
to figure out how to do that and you
know Phil Jackson was great at then Phil
wouldn't just coached the team I'll
coach the game but he'd read everything
about every single player we heard about
your history how you grew up how you
were raised where we were were you
raised you know he'll read every
interview and he'll learn about you and
give us him a better understanding of
what's motivating you or what your
insecurities are right and then it just
helps them communicate with you better
or even push a button here if he needs
to there was a stretch and o3 where Shaq
was out with an injury and Phil called
me up to his office and said okay we
need you to really turn on the
afterburners to start scoring or you
have to win so I did and I wound up
scoring I think it was nine straight
games for 40-plus points nine straight
nights free games and then Shaq comes
back second it's second to last game of
that and then Phil calls me ups was
office is cold okay I need you to dial
it back
I'm like why I like wait I don't
understand
is because our goal is to win a
championship mmm and we can get to the
Western Conference with you playing this
way but in the East you know we can
dominate them inside with Shaq in the
post but if you continue to do this
we'll lose Shaq will lose him his
motivation his excitement triggers him
right so I need you to pull back so we
can pull Shaq forward for June and I
just looked at him like smart dude Wow
yeah this is what smart dude mess up who
pulled the bag how important is it to
have that team and and to all those who
are watching that are starting out their
teams what would be the advice that you
would give them
yeah well the the whole solopreneur
thing I'm gonna do it by myself I'm
gonna work from home that's it's not
even real like I know it's popular you
see it on Instagram and you think some
guys doing something on Instagram that
he's not doing anything posted he posted
an image of his car then he washes on
instant
okay okay it might not even be his car
by the way
okay he's rubbing out his car and posted
somebody else's car he posted a picture
of Edmunds car as he passed up here in
the hills so after he freaking mowed my
lawn so what would I tell you dude you
got to be on a team I mean like like how
are you going anyplace by yourself you
live in a planet with 7 billion people
you're like I hear people say all the
time I don't I you know I'm an extra I'm
an introvert and I don't like people do
you live on planet Earth right okay kind
of the wrong place to enter so you know
I know people that can't swim I'm like
two-thirds of the planet is water hey
jump in this pool you might want to get
you stroke zone dog I mean there's a
chance in your lifetime that you're
going to need people and you might need
a backstroke right you night might need
to go the whole you breath at some point
so so like I don't understand why people
aren't getting prepared we live on a
planet that is basically it's got
gravity on it it's got an atmosphere and
there's one common thing whether you're
Chinese Hispanic
I don't think Hispanics even up a group
is it Latinos and ok ok sorry man
ok you got blacks you got white you got
Italians you got all these people right
Koreans you got we got all these people
but the truth is man economics to bind
us all together ok I go down to the
grocery store there's somebody from
Korea in there I'm trading money with
that person ok that that is the exchange
you're on a team your team can be your
team that has the goal they want to go
get us to sell hit a target but part of
your team is also the people you're
selling to right and part of your team
is also another team is the community
you live in and another another team is
your church yeah you know and your
family man these are all teams right and
your job in my job I mean if you want to
be all alive all in the deal your job is
to keep all you need to be a frickin
super champion of all these teams right
not just one team one
the most important work ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be kind of like a little
beacon if you want more salmon sign like
check out the start with why video that
we made on him I think you're really
gonna enjoy the link is right there next
to me continue to believe and I'll see
you there
the why was born out of pain it was
never an academic or commercial exercise